please consider supporting the channel
on patreon link is in the description
Angels Heavenly winged beings who guide
lost souls to Salvation
or are they many eyed Cosmic Horrors
that terrify innocent people minding
their own business well either way
angels are an important part of the
abrahamic religions but did you know
that according to some groups within
these religions there are many different
types of angels today we'll look into
the Angelic hierarchy put forward by the
medieval Catholic Church
laughs
before we continue here's a quick word
from our sponsor and that sponsor is
atlasvpn we all like the internet right
with the internet we can learn new
things shop online and chat with friends
all over the world but the modern
Internet isn't always safe and that's
where Atlas VPN comes in Atlas VPN
protects your internet travel which
means your data will be protected from
invasive tracking snooping and the
dangers of public Wi-Fi enjoy amazingly
fast speeds and protect an unlimited
number of devices and it even helps you
get the best deals When shopping online
but here's my favorite part so let's say
like me you want to watch Friends on
Netflix but you live in America where
friends and many other television series
and movies aren't available well no
problem just load up Atlas VPN scroll
down pick the UK and boom A Whole New
World of TV shows and movies are
available to you right now Atlas VPN is
running a big deal Atlas VPN premium is
now just 199 per month plus three months
extra and with with a 30-day money-back
guarantee protect your privacy and get
the many benefits of Atlas VPN for this
ridiculously low price you can take this
deal by clicking the link in the video
description below be quick as it's a
limited time offer thank you again to
Atlas VPN for sponsoring this video
so first off let's define what an angel
even is the term angel comes from the
Greek Angelos which is a translation of
the Hebrew malach meaning messenger
in the Hebrew Bible and in the Greek New
Testament the word refers to both
Heavenly and human Messengers
but once the Bible was translated into
Latin the meanings split human
Messengers were referred to with words
like nantius or legatus while Heavenly
Messengers were referred to as angels
from then on all Heavenly beings save
God were called angels
but there is an argument to be made that
calling all Heavenly Spirits Angels is
inaccurate the Bible uses many terms for
angels and this hierarchy reflects that
that said I'll still be using angel to
refer to them all generally
so where did this hierarchy come from is
it from the Bible
well no it's not while the Bible does
describe the Angel Michael as archangel
meaning Prince Angel no other hint at a
specific hierarchy is present so what
gives well in Thomas aquinas's Summa
theologica perhaps the most important
book on Catholic theology ever written
Aquinas does indeed lay out a hierarchy
in heaven
Aquinas states that there are three
hierarchies within the Angelic Order
each containing three choirs but where
did he get these ideas did he make them
up whole cloth no instead he cites a man
called dionysius and it is from his
writings where we discover the origin of
the idea Dionysus the areopagite was a
man mentioned as a student of Paul the
Apostle in the book of Acts many books
were attributed to him in the Middle
Ages and his association with Paul gave
the works a certain amount of apostolic
credibility and one of these books was
the celestial hierarchy
we now know that the man who wrote the
book was not Dionysus the areopagite or
at least not the one that we know from
the book of Acts he was instead a
neoplatonic philosopher living in Syria
or thereabouts during the 5th Century
but medieval people like Aquinas thought
he was the real thing so with all that
finally out of the way here's the
hierarchy
starting from the bottom we have Angels
archangels and principalities this
hierarchy was the closest to Mankind and
their responsibilities reflected that
so starting with angels yep just plain
Angels these are your bog standard
Celestial Messengers from God in the
Bible they tend to take on human form so
I've decided not to give this one any
wings
an example from Genesis is when Three
Angels well one might have been God
visit Abraham Abraham looked up and saw
three men standing near him he ran from
the tent entrance to meet them and bowed
down to the ground
if you've ever heard of a guardian angel
these are the angels that would have
that task
Thomas Aquinas who separated the ranks
of angels based on their knowledge of
the universe said these angels had the
least understanding of God's plans and
were ordered to be Protectors of
individuals and Families
next up we have Arc Angels by the name
you'd think they were at the top of the
Heap but no according to Medieval
Catholic theology they're right here
second from the bottom archangels
deliver the most important messages and
do the most important jobs for God on
Earth they are also the only Angels who
have given names well if you don't count
fallen angels that is
there are two named angels that every
Christian agrees on the first is the
Archangel Gabriel his name means God is
my strength and he is the foremost
messenger of God we first meet him in
the Book of Daniel where he explains a
vision the prophet had seen he most
famously to Christians was the angel
that announced the coming of Christ to
Mary in the Gospel of Luke he's not
actually called an archangel in the
Bible but other works like The Book of
Enoch do describe him this way
and Catholic Orthodox anglicans and
lutherans call him Archangel as well
next we have Michael his name means who
is like God and he is chief of the
Angels protector of Israel and the
church he's mentioned briefly in the
Book of Daniel as well he's more heavily
featured in the New Testament however
most prominently in the Book of
Revelations where he defeats the devil
in the form of a great dragon
these two angels are agreed to be
archangels by most Christians as they're
mentioned in the bible but there are two
others usually included Raphael whose
name means God heals is in the Book of
Tobit a book of the Old Testament
accepted by the Catholics and Orthodox
but not by Protestants who place it in
the Apocrypha it's also not included in
the modern Jewish Bible though Raphael
is mentioned in the talmud lastly yoriel
whose name means flame of God is found
in the second book of estrus a book
considered apocryphal by most Christian
churches but some include it regardless
these four archangels are accepted by
many Christian denominations
so the top of the lowest hierarchy are
the principalities their name along with
the names of three other choirs of
angels will get to come from a single
line in Colossians one of Paul's letters
for in him all things in heaven and on
Earth were created things visible and
invisible whether Thrones or dominions
or rulers or Powers all things have been
created through him and for him this
line is a bit hard to parse honestly but
dionysius interpreted these names as
ranks of angels
principalities are thought to have
responsibility over large groups of
people like Nations churches and other
large organizations because of this they
don't tend to interact with individuals
so on to the middle hierarchy this one
includes Powers virtues and dominions
these angels deal little with humans
honestly little of substance is written
about this hierarchy both by dionysius
and Aquinas powers are Warrior angels
and they make up a large portion of
God's Celestial army they have the power
to suppress evil and demonic forces
virtues whose name doesn't seem to be in
the Bible or well obviously the word
Virtue is in the Bible but I couldn't
find where Dionysus possibly thought the
word referred to an angel anyway in
later writings especially of the
esoteric variety virtues have power over
the elements meaning they make natural
phenomena happen
they also have a hand in the Miracles on
Earth that are meant to lead people to
Salvation and highest of the middle
hierarchy are dominions they are only
described as having dominion over Angels
below them so I guess they're like the
middle management of Heaven
and now to the highest hierarchy
consisting of Thrones cherubim and
seraphim they seem to spend almost all
of their time with God in heaven and
have little if anything to do with
humans Thrones are perhaps the most
famous rank in the biblically accurate
Angel iconography yep these are the ones
that look like Wheels with eyes on them
that image comes from Ezekiel in one of
his visions
their appearance was like the gleaming
of barrel and the four had the same form
their construction being something like
a wheel within a wheel when they moved
they moved in any of the four directions
without veering as they moved their rims
were tall and awesome for the rims of
all four were full of eyes all around
so pretty weird right most Scholars take
this account as a metaphor a way of
describing the wheels of God's throne
and some artists even interpret this as
Circles of angels flying around God in
heaven not that the Angels themselves
looked like Wheels
anyway their job is to hold up God's
Heavenly throne
next are the cherubim cherubim are quite
famous referenced in songs and of course
in art where they are often depicted as
Cupids or puto young babies with wings
while this depiction proved popular in
Renaissance and baroque art it is not
how cherubs look in the Bible in fact
the two depictions couldn't be further
from each other the first time we meet a
cherub is in Genesis where God places
one holding a flaming sword to guard the
Garden of Eden it seems this was the
main function of the cherubim to guard
sacred spaces
for example two images of cherubim were
placed Atop The Ark of the Covenant and
in ezekiel's Vision the cherubim were
guarding God's Throne so what do these
angels look like if not babies well
Ezekiel gives quite a description he
says they had four faces one of a man
one of a bull one of a lion and the last
of an eagle they had two sets of wings
two wrapped around themselves and two
used to fly some art depicts them with
the bodies of beasts as well
but since they are sometimes described
as holding things or having hands and
feet I've drawn this one like this this
depiction of a human animal hybrid was
very common in Middle Eastern mythology
and religion think of the Sphinx in
Egypt or the lamasu from Assyria
oh and if you were wondering in what
level the devil resided before his fall
from Heaven Aquinas as well as other
medieval theologians thought he was a
fallen cherub
the very last Angels the highest of them
all are the seraphim we see them most
prominently in Isaiah chapter 6 where
again the prophet describes a vision he
had he said that seraphim surrounded
God's Throne they had six wings two
covering their eyes two covering their
feet and two used to fly
they are the tenders to God's throne and
constantly sing holy holy holy is the
Lord of hosts the whole Earth is filled
with his glory the name seraphim is
usually translated as burning ones this
could mean they were beings of fire or
light but the word serif actually means
serpent they're never depicted as snakes
though there have been some Scholars
that suggest they ought to be
the usual explanation is that snakes are
sometimes red like fire or that their
venom burns like fire
so there we are the nine ranks of angels
seraphim cherubim Thrones dominions
virtues Powers principalities archangels
and angels
I hope you enjoyed make sure to like And
subscribe and support me on patreon also
thanks again to atlasvpn remember to
click the link in the description to get
their special offer while you still can
bye